Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Today we are going to talk about
language learning edge number four and
that is focus.
Focus comes first.
A lot of people who really get into
learning languages as a passion and as a
hobby,
they have a certain weakness and that
weakness is that they are visionary,
they are too visionary,
they have too many new ideas all the
time,
too many things that they want to try
too many things that they want to do.
Too many things that they want to create
sometimes.
Now in some ways that's awesome.
That's very good for being creative and
for getting new ideas and setting new
goals,
but it can also be a distraction because
it's difficult to focus on one thing for
a long enough to achieve it.
Right?
Maybe you start to learn French,
but then you read a little bit about the
other romance languages and you want to
start studying Italian or Spanish or
something.
Maybe you're learning Arabic and then
you think,
hmm,
it would be interesting to learn Hebrew
too and see how they're related.
So it's very easy to get sidetracked
from the language that you want to be
focusing on at the moment.
If you really think about it,
who gets good at new skills the most
quickly?
It's probably people who get really
obsessed with that skill are really
obsessed with learning and practicing
around that topic and that's because
they're dedicating so much of their
mental resources to that skill or to
that topic.
You might think that if you study French
for one hour that that's the same as
studying French for one hour plus
Spanish for one hour.
Like you will be learning the same
amount of French in both scenarios.
But I would say that that's not true and
that's because a lot of the learning
takes place when you're not studying.
It takes place in the background.
Subconsciously you're processing and
you're synthesizing all the things
you've studied in the background while
you're going about your day and doing
other things.
Sometimes if you are in tune with that
kind of inner voice,
you can notice that you'll notice in the
background,
your mind is making sentences in the
language while you're driving or while
you're on the train or while you're
talking to someone you can,
you can be aware of some of that
processing going on so that learning is
taking place when you're not studying,
but if you are focusing on two different
languages,
if you're studying Spanish for one hour
a day and you're studying French for one
hour a day,
then that subconscious background
processes being divided between two
different languages so you're not
getting as much of that growth going on
in the background.
Even if you dedicate the same amount of
study times to that language.
So the most efficient way to learn one
language really well is to focus on that
language and that language alone.
Now,
how do you do that if you're one of
those visionary people who get all those
ideas,
how do you kind of manage all the ideas
and all the goals that you have where
you have to kind of get used to pushing
certain goals?
Often to the distance into the future,
I wouldn't think of pushing them aside
or putting them behind you.
I would think of putting them off into
the future.
So after you finish achieving this
current goal right now,
for example,
getting really good at French in the
future.
Beyond that,
you can see the next goal in front of
you,
which is to start learning Spanish or
whatever your language of interest.
Yes.
But just think of it like that.
Like you're not discarding those goals
are discarding those missions you were,
you were kind of putting them off into
the future and you'll get to them later.
But your primary mission right now is
this one which you need to accomplish
first before you can get to that future
mission.
So I've been talking about focus in the
grand sense,
like in terms of your large goals and
that kind of thing.
But of course focus is also important in
the moment because we live in such a
distraction,
prawn world with the Internet and with
smartphones and with email and all those
things,
there's just,
there's so much distraction all around
you all the time that it's difficult to
focus on the task at hand.
Even if you have put all of your
secondary goal is often to the future,
just focusing on your primary goal.
It can be tough just on a day by day
basis.
We all have our different weaknesses.
Some people get caught up in facebook,
some people like me get caught up in
youtube,
like I get caught up in all of the
videos in the sidebar.
I'll end up watching 20 videos when I
planned to just watch one and that kind
of thing.
So it's really easy to get off track and
lose focus of what your goal is for that
day.
So it's important to not leave it to
willpower.
It's important to have some strategies
in place and make some decisions that
will help guide your behavior when
you're trying to get something done.
Avoiding distractions and staying
focused is a little different for
everyone.
But I'll give you a couple of things
that I used to deal with these
situations.
Maybe you have some other ideas that you
can share in the comments.
One of my strategies for avoiding
distractions is that I have a kind of
transition activity.
It's a one kind of study or one kind of
study method that I find enjoyable
that's really easy for me to get started
at that I don't hesitate or
procrastinate when starting,
and that's kind of my stepping stone
into studying.
So for me that is listening passively to
the news in my target language.
I really enjoy that.
It's relaxing,
it's kind of meditative.
I can just sit there and just commonly
listen and that's an easy way for me to
get into that language is mode.
So if I'm listening to French on the
news,
I can sit there and relax,
but then I start to notice words.
I'm like,
Hey,
what does that word mean?
And I'll pick up my dictionary and look
it up and I'll start to get curious.
I'll start to get into French study
mode.
And then after that I'm going to pick up
my books and I'm going to start studying
and then that kind of thing will happen.
I'll transition into studying French
through that easy activity that I enjoy
doing and that's kind of a low
investment activity for me.
So maybe that's something you can try
it.
If you really like listening to songs in
your target language,
that can be your transition into
studying or if you really just like
talking to people,
maybe you can go on facebook and chat
with some native speakers in that
language,
leave some comments in that language,
just getting that interaction,
but whatever it is for you,
that's kind of low commitment and easy
to get started with,
but is in your target language.
That's a good way to transition into
studying.
Another important thing is to actually
physically block out distractions.
Like sometimes I pick up my phone,
my smartphone,
and I put it in the other room so that
it won't be distracting to me.
I always have the ringer turned off and
when I'm focusing on studying,
I'll turn off all of the notifications
like no facebook notifications,
no line APP notifications,
nothing like that.
But sometimes I'll still be interested
in picking up my phone in and checking
something,
but if I want to avoid that I'll just
pick it up and put it in the other room.
So it's kind of a hassle to get up and
go do that.
The benefit of actually picking up the
phone is not as big as the hassle of
going to get it,
so it's good to sometimes just remove
those distractions from your
environment.
Another thing that I don't really do but
some of my friends do is to use a kind
of software or application that blocks
websites that you find particularly
distracting.
Like there's one,
uh,
this one software called cold Turkey and
there's another one that is called stay
focused.
That's a chrome add on that you can use
to block certain websites.
Like,
let's say you get caught up in facebook
all the time,
or you visit tech crunch blog all the
time,
but you want to just stay away from
those for a while.
You can put those in your block list.
So then whenever you turn on that
software,
it'll block those websites.
And I think you can specify a certain
period of time as well so that you can't
just go in and change the settings
whenever you want and will actually
block you,
um,
based on the time you decide in advance.
So you can kind of change your mind in
the middle.
You've already fixed the blockage of
those websites.
So that's another thing you can try if
you're distracted by any specific
websites.
Another thing that I do to stay focused
is I listened to binaural beats track on
Youtube.
I just search for binaural beats
concentration and one of those videos
will come up.
I have a specific one that I liked that
I always listened to.
So you can try a few of them to see
which one helps you focus and just put
on your headphones and while you're
studying,
use that.
Uh,
you can do it when you're just studying
with your textbook,
but also if you're using audio
materials,
you can play both at the same time.
If it's on your computer,
you can play that youtube track,
but you can also use your cds and just
have them playing over top of each other
and it's fine.
You can turn down the binaural beats a
little bit and just listen to the audio
track mainly.
But the binaural beats be there in the
background kind of helping you focus.
Some people say that binaural beats
don't work.
There's no scientific basis.
Well,
if it helps you focus,
then it works.
So it doesn't really matter if it's
scientifically proven or not.
Try it,
see if it helps you.
All right,
so those are some of my ideas on how to
stay focused.
Focus comes first.
It's important for learning the language
that you really want to get good at.
All right.
This is Paul and this is Lang Focus.
Thank you for tuning in.
Have a good day.
When you were an infant,
you spend about a year just sitting
there and listening to the language
before you actually say anything,
just absorbing the sounds.
You were internalizing the phonology
before you actually produce it as an
adult.
Do you have a year to sit around doing
that?
I know I don't.
I've met a lot of people who are great
with languages while traveling and also
in my regular life,
and I'd like to talk about a couple of
particularly impressive people that we
can learn something from.